over here yes so the movie was so moving
and healing for our community after a
wave of anti-acc what was it like for
you to play your character who
approaches everything with kindness
first and how is that shaped the key
standing for us today well you know this
was uh this was a role that I wanted for
a long long time and not only is it a
great movie but it's also a great
message and just like you said you know
our movie is about love about kindness
about empathy and acceptance and uh and
it means everything to me uh uh and I'm
just so grateful that
the audience you know embrace our movie
uh and I just could not believe that I
was given this amazing opportunity by
the Daniels and also to be able to work
with Michelle yo Lee Michelle yo the
Jamie Lee Curtis and and of course the
incomparable James Hong was just a dream
come true
yes
hi
um where are you
okay hi hi
character media
um so uh by the way thank you for that
wonderful award
yes congratulations again thank you
thank you
[Music]
you know when I decided back I decided
to get back into acting I mean I said
this before and this is it could not be
more true I just wanted a job uh in fact
you know I I remember talking to my
agent and I said do you think I can get
a series regular role uh where it is
stable so for me to be in this position
is really beyond anything I could have
ever imagined now I haven't acted in so
long uh one I could not believe I was
given this role and now moving forward I
really want to play all kinds of roles
that wouldn't that was not available for
me when I was much much younger uh of
course I'm grateful the landscape has
changed there was a lot more progress
now and and suddenly there's you know
the Asian representation is here so I
just want to to keep an open mind and
and to see what's out there yeah
oh you're so kind you know I remember
during the pandemic this was after we
finished maybe but it hasn't come out
yet and I was auditioning left and right
and I could not land a single job uh and
I was so worried that uh you know maybe
I'm not good at this uh so now is I'm
sorry I'm so excited so nervous ask me
that question again please
okay well first of all no
I I am not I'm not Tom Cruise I'm not
Brad Pitt I'm not Leonardo DiCaprio but
I think uh and I hope that there is a
lot more opportunities now I hope that a
lot more filmmakers uh is thinking of me
a lot more casting directors is thinking
of me and uh I'm really excited and
optimistic moving forward uh so I I
don't know what tomorrow is going to be
uh but hey I just want to go for the
globe
[Applause]
thank you congratulations Anthony from
deadline building on his question
everyone wants to see a Goonies reunion
has has anyone approached you about it
is there is this even
an inch more of reality since you've
come back to the big screen as Stephen
or anyone talked to you about well first
of all we have the big man here tonight
Steven Spielberg and and that would be
one question that I think all of us want
to ask him you know honestly for the
last 30 something years we have tried to
do a Goonies too in fact when I was much
younger I wish it would come to pass
because that was a movie that I thought
I would need to make a career come back
uh and honestly I think they work really
hard we had numerous scripts but there
was not one script that that that felt
uh uh it could be you know it could live
up to what the you know the original uh
was uh and you know I'm sadly we lost
the captain level ship dick Donner whom
I love dearly and I really don't know if
there's going to be Goonies too uh but I
will be open to revisiting that
character data if there is an
opportunity
what's been your favorite moment so far
in this comeback you've been having
it there is a lot of favorite moments of
of mine uh in fact ever since a movie
came out it has been an incredible ride
I has been unbelievable but I think the
most memorable is you know for the
longest time people have come up to me
uh and they would say are you the kid
from Indiana Jones are you the kid from
Goonies but now when I go out people say
oh my gosh you're Wayman from everything
everywhere all at once and that was what
I always hoped would happen uh and also
just meeting the fans in person and
hearing them talk about our movie and
How Deeply it resonated with them in
fact a lot of fans have come up to me
and said it has changed their life and
when we talk about the our movie they
would literally cry in front of me and
also make me cry so that is definitely
one of the most memorable moments uh
since our movie came out
[Music]